these are the faces of those on the NHS
front line their commitment to keeping
us safe captured on canvas by dozens of
artists including Alistair Adams he's
painted countless actors and politicians
his work of Tony Blair famously hangs in
the National Portrait Gallery but at a
dark time Aleister wanted to honor those
not usually in the spotlight
I don't know Deborah terribly well at
all and so as a result what I'm playing
and painting really I suppose is the
notion of somebody that's kind of
upstanding and forthright and I'm
holding the line the person is there but
because we don't know the person
necessarily very well we're sort of like
using her as a metaphor for the greater
sort of sense of the time really despite
having never met Michele produced a
picture of Paula a nurse working in
neuro intensive care she's got a three
year old son and a five month old
daughter I think that's right and her
son when she opened it when she opened
the package her son that she said he's
mummy so when she told me that I thought
oh well I've definitely done a good job
the virtual exhibition is both beautiful
and moving particularly for those in
them Stan works as a theatre technician
in hospitals across the Midlands he was
painted by his friend that portrait to
me it will be a keepsake and it will
always remind you know myself my kids
even the grandchildren because it holds
history behind it and it shows how the
Solidarity which the NHS staff has gone
through and over the past 10 days or
months
traditionally portraits were seen as a
symbol of status the artists say these
paintings immortalize our heroes for
generations to come
it's hoped when life returns to normal
an exhibition will be open to celebrate
the portraits so the sacrifice of the
people in them is never forgotten a
Shannara nags Sky News